une nuit à minuit passé
partez en arrière et là vous commencez à
convulser
et nous accueillons notre terrien du
samedi 20h ce soir Christophe Lamarre
bonsoir
je suis très heureux de vous recevoir ce
soir
car vous êtes l'un des vrais héros de
notre monde moderne je dirais un
symptôme qui donne sa vie pour soigner
les plus pauvres des plus pauvres
[Musique]
vous êtes né le 16 février 1966 sur le
plateau de Creil dans l'Oise votre père
est ingénieur chez Schneider Electric
votre mère est directrice d'école en Z
et à l'époque sur le plateau de Creil
tout le monde bosse à l'usine et
travaille dur pour gagner sa croûte
tout le monde bosse idéologie du travail
au moins le père et qui sont bien payés
petit vous êtes souvent malade asthme
infection respiratoire et le médecin
vient souvent à la maison évidemment
pour vous soigner et vous en faites
votre modèle à 14 ans vous entrez dans
la protection civile et à 16 ans vous
devenez pompier volontaire et c'est là
que vous découvrez l'hôpital et vous
dites c'est ça mon truc je ne ferai pas
autre chose c'était c'était compliqué
parce que j'étais pas un très très bon
élève dans les années supérieures à
l'école primaire ça allait j'étais un
peu dissipé et je me disais il va
falloir que je me calme que je commence
à bosser parce que je sens que je
saurais rien faire d'autre
meurt d'épuisement
et vous vous allez encore y rester 17
ans ouais j'ai pas compris
je me suis dit qu'il avait dû il avait
du pas bien faire avec moi j'allais y
arriver alors vous achetez un hangar
pour y créer une maison médicale avec un
kiné un gynécologue un orthophoniste
alors au début vous fermez à 20h puis à
22h puis à minuit et un matin vous
sortez il fait jour voilà je me suis dit
un truc qui va plus alors vous voyez une
mer alcoolique par exemple qui a oublié
de changer les couches de son bébé le
bébé allait fesses en sang puis les
femmes battues ça c'était terrible le
mari de l'une d'entre elles lui avait
cassé la mâchoire à coudre ranger et
elle va à l'hôpital pour se faire mettre
des fils évidemment en acier dans la
bouche mais elle refuse de retourner à
l'hôpital pour les enlever et c'est vous
qui êtes obligé de le faire vous-même
avec une pince coupante que vous allez
chercher dans la boîte à outils de votre
voiture et sans anesthésie un bon coup
de rouge c'est tout
son mari finira par lui rouler sur la
tête avec sa voiture quoi on la voit se
trimballer en déambulateur de temps en
temps encore
en 2000 le gouvernement Jospin met en
place la couverture médicale universelle
donc ceux qui gagnent plus de 700 € par
mois sont obligés d'avancer l'argent
quand ils vont chez le toubib
arumatologue qui va vous faire des
infiltrations s'il en fait une de chaque
côté c'est 100 euros et c'est pour
quelqu'un qui gagne 1000 euros par mois
c'est c'est impossible donc il va rester
avec ses genoux douloureux ce qui fait
Christophe que vous retrouvez vous en
train de faire des infilts oui si je me
fais choper c'est un défendable quoi
complètement si je fou une infection on
va dire mais vous avez pas à faire ça
c'est les rhumatos mais bon il y a aussi
l'histoire d'un mec c'est terrible qui
vous fait un chèque de 6,90 € et qui
vous dit s'il vous plaît encaissez-le le
mois prochain
moi je dis vite vite barrer sur le
Touraine faites-nous le tiers payant
intégral pour que les travailleurs
pauvres puissent se soigner dignement
n'est pas de retard au diagnostic pas de
perte de chance
puisqu'on n'arrête pas de dire que les
gens faut les remettre au travail
il faut qu'il se lève le matin et bah
ceux qui sont ceux qui se sont remis au
travail et qui se lèvent le matin ont en
fin de mois pas les moyens de se soigner
ni eux ni leurs enfants il vaut mieux
être très très pauvre avoir la CMU pour
se soigner que de bosser et dans des
métiers durs puisque c'est un site pas
les gens à travailler parce que
au-dessus de 700 euros voilà c'est vous
qui avancez le pognon pour les toubibs
c'est ça voilà c'est ça celui qui gagne
le SMIC il a le boulot le plus dur puis
en fin de mois il peut pas se soigner
alors au cours des années 2000 vous
travaillez 16 heures par jour et un jour
vous faites même 104 consultations dans
la journée la sécu a pété les plombs oui
parce que le rodateur classique
1h du matin ils étaient pas là ils
voient pas ce que je fais eux ils
relèvent les compteurs c'est tout
et en 2007 une nuit à minuit passée
partait en arrière et là vous commencez
à convulser
[Rires]
j'étais tellement exténué tellement au
bout du rouleau que après une journée de
dingue et les deux nuits précédentes à
presque pas dormir en hiver j'ai conçu
vous dites quand on soigne les gens on
oublie la fatigue ouais ouais tout à
fait tout à fait c'est remarquable
10 jours plus tard vous avez appris le
service et vous recommencez vos journées
de 16h vous êtes toujours ouvert mon
cabinet c'était la version médicale de
l'épicerie
6 mois plus tard nouvelle crise
d'épilation et voilà voilà vous dites je
vais mourir dans mon cabinet comme mon
associé va falloir changer un peu de
braquer là vous vous installez au
centre-ville à Roubaix et vous trouvez
des gens pour qui même le hard discount
est trop cher vous dites qui se servent
chez ABC qui récupère des palettes de
conserve à 6 mois de la date de
péremption ouais puis des fruits et
légumes que les que les magasins normaux
ne veulent pas il faut trier ce qui est
incroyable c'est que l'économie locale
c'est adapté à la pauvreté des gens et
puis vous découvrez qu'il y a encore
plus pauvre que les pauvres les robes
j'ai soigné les rhums il y avait un
campement Rome quasiment dans le centre
ville de Roubaix
une vingtaine de mètres de mon cabinet
moi j'avais pas l'habitude et là je me
suis rendu compte que il y avait encore
en dessous quoi il y a des gens qui ont
rien mais alors rien du tout et là
c'était compliqué pour les soigner
compliqué quand ton expulse les Roms on
reste tout au bulldozer même les
cartables des enfants et les médicaments
terribles alors ce qui les aident ce
sont le Secours Catholique et la mosquée
ouais voilà la main dans la main alors
quand on parle de communautarisme
de république laïque c'est quand même la
République laïque qui les a viré sur le
trottoir et ceux qui les ont aidé c'est
c'est les musulmans qui ont amené tout
de suite de la bouffe
tout de suite ils m'ont appelé ils m'ont
téléphoné ils m'ont dit on arrive on
débarque et vous vous les hébergez dans
votre ancien voilà le cabinet dans
lequel j'ai failli mourir votre hangar
que j'ai pas voulu vendre j'ai pas
pourquoi mais bon
il y a quasiment 400 mètres carrés donc
il y avait de la place alors l'avenir
vous êtes assez pessimiste quand même
fait stop vous avez peur parce que les
enfants qui naissent aujourd'hui
il travaille pas mais ils ont pas vu
leurs parents travailler et donc
finalement c'est la perte de la valeur
travail quoi vous dites on est parti
pour un siècle de pauvreté si on fait
pas quelque chose très très vite pour
récupérer ces gamins qui ont plus la
valeur du travail du tout du tout du
tout et puis qui voit d'autres gosses
qui se font 1000 euros par jour en
vendant du site c'est sûr que là ça va
poser un gros problème voilà vous dites
si les services publics disparaissent de
ces quartiers c'est l'émeutes c'est
terrible c'est terrible là
le gouvernement a pas intérêt à s'amuser
à ça parce que les gens moi je sais les
gens sont sur le fil vraiment sur le fil
il suffirait d'une toute petite baisse
il suffira qu'ils aient un petit peu
faim que un de leur gosse ne puisse pas
soigner et finissent handicapés ou très
malade ou meurent et là ça pète on est
on n'est pas loin et moi j'ai
l'impression que que le service public
saupoudre en fonction de de ce fil n'est
pas casser si il voit que ça se tend un
petit peu il va saupoudrer un petit peu
plus s'il voit que ça relâche il attend
et on joue avec cette limite en fait et
c'est ça c'est très malsain dans mon
activité d'abord la médecine générale
c'est il faut absolument faciliter
l'accès aux soins des travailleurs
pauvres ça c'est essentiel oui voilà ça
ouais elle a dit aussi on se mettra en
place en 2017 moi je voudrais qu'elle
fasse sa vie parce que
ça incite pas les autres à bosser que de
voir qu'ils peuvent pas aller chez le
médecin c'est un truc de base après il
faut absolument remettre les les gens au
travail même si c'est pas un travail
essentiel qui rapporte quelque chose qui
apporte quelque chose à la communauté il
faut absolument que leur gamin voit que
les gens bosse ils se lève le matin eux
vont à l'école et le papa ou la maman ou
les deux vont bosser ça c'est essentiel
et la deuxième chose il y a que l'école
de la République laïque qui peut sortir
les gamins de là où ils sont
leur donner l'impression qu'ils ont leur
chance et que la censure sociale grâce à
l'école il est encore là et là c'est pas
du tout ce qui est en train de se passer
merci de votre témoignage docteur merci
de m'avoir invité
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu